where's the jungle this is a whole new
thing nobody told us we added to a whole
new thing
I'm coming grabbed by Eddie morning did
you guys see Spencer is that think he
went back in we gotta go get him Florida
oh my god my joints feel like myself I
came back and things actually got worse
look at this
whoa - dude you have some issues here
the game is busted
listen up now this is a dangerous place
you've got to have eyes in the back
Sam he'll just happen to him
would you look at me I haven't looked
like this since and ever you look like
this never I think my eyes are a
different color all of you is a
different color strengths and weaknesses
Linguistics whole goodness nunchucks
that's new
damn that's a good list weaknesses heat
Sun and sang how is this guy a character
in an adventure game we have to find
Spencer and Bethany
adventure is even more challenging
this time not all of you will leave the
gang
Besame thought you might need some help
where is Bethenny she's right here she
says oh my god like I'm a total horse
[Music]
it's terrible job what are you talking
about that's passed my driver's test
last month that's gay we're not gonna
make it we're gonna make it hopefully
we're gonna make it we're gonna make it
we're not gonna make it
[Music]
what happened yes I'm back I missed you
so much oh my god you guys hi Bethany
you guys were back in Jumanji
you